CBS News has confirmed more than 20,000
people who live or work in nursing homes
and other long-term care facilities have
died from the corona virus the nursing
home industry is now seeking immunity
from lawsuits tied to the outbreak at
least 15 states have passed some off of
passed laws offering some legal
protection Jonathan Vigliotti looks at
efforts in California to hold those
facilities accountable for their care he
was kind and he was gentle and he was
brilliant scott Acree describes his
father 88 year-old Castell acree as a
devoted family man and a leader in his
community he died alone last month in a
northern california nursing home after
contracting coronavirus he was the first
person in our family to graduate from
college he died six legs short of being
able to see his grandson graduate from
college six months acree was admitted to
the Gateway care and rehabilitation
center for a short recovery stay after a
diabetic episode he was one of at least
13 people at Gateway who died at least
69 patients and 33 employees have tested
positive at one point during the
outbreak a Cree says he was told that
staff members were not being tested and
were handling up to 35 patients at a
time there's no question that while the
virus is an act of God the crisis in
California's nursing home facilities is
an act of man at least 733 long-term
care residents in 15 health care workers
have died in California Mike dark is a
lawyer for the California advocates for
nursing home reform at the nursing homes
that are suffering the worst problems
with the virus are the same homes that
have had terrible track records with
infection control and with staffing CBS
News dug into the federal records in
Falmouth nearly 62% of California
nursing homes including Gateway were
cited for infection prevention and
control APS's last year out of the ten
California facilities with the highest
number of resident kovat cases seven
received only one
or two stars on a federal rating scale
which looks in part at staffing and
health inspections nursing home
operators cut staffing to maximize
profit and when you don't have enough
staff it's simply not possible to have
good infection control dark says
lawsuits are one way of forcing change
and holding facilities accountable it is
very possible that a wave of lawsuits
could ultimately wipe out a significant
portion of long-term care profession
mark Regan is general counsel for the
California Association of health
facilities one of six health care groups
asking California's governor to issue an
executive order granting immunity
we have caregivers who are doing their
absolute best every day against
impossible odds and to allow the
second-guessing of those caregivers
would be really unfortunate agree who
has now hired an attorney himself hopes
this devastating outbreak can bring
meaningful change in senior care we
don't want this to happen to anybody
else because this was just wrong and we
can now report the Alameda County
District Attorney's Office is conducting
a criminal investigation into gateway
the owners of the facility reportedly
own at least seven other nursing homes
they've not returned our calls for
comment nursing home advocacy group say
state inspectors and nursing homes
should take infection control violations
more seriously
and they say immunity would undermine
that effort Anthony a truly devastating
situation there in California Jonathan
thank you